et c'est indéniablement
l'île secrète la plus stratégique.
Cet endroit s'appelle Svalbard.
L'île est à cheval entre les deux voies maritimes
que la flotte russe du Nord emprunte pour rejoindre les eaux plus chaudes.
Et aussi, grâce à son emplacement,
on peut y contrôler chaque satellite placé en orbite polaire
sur toutes les orbites.
C'est le lieu stratégique ultime.
Le changement climatique a fortement réduit les glaciers de la région,
augmentant massivement l'activité humaine
et l'île devient une poudrière.
D'ailleurs, l'Assemblée Parlementaire de l'OTAN
va se réunir à Svalbard le mois prochain.
Les Russes n'apprécient pas du tout cette décision.
Alors, si vous cherchez une poudrière en Arctique,
regardez bien Svalbard.
Chez les militaires,
on sait depuis des décennies, voire des siècles,
que le temps de préparation,
que ce soit pour un ouragan, un typhon, ou des changements stratégiques,
est avant la frappe.
Et l'Amiral Nimitz avait raison.
Il faut se préparer avant.
Heureusement, notre secrétaire à la Défense,
Jim Mattis, l'a aussi très bien compris.
Et ce qu'il a compris, c'est que le climat est un risque.
Il l'a exprimé par écrit au Congrès et il a dit :
« En tant que Secrétaire à la Défense,
je dois gérer ce genre de risque. »
Les militaires américains ne sont pas les seuls à comprendre cela.
Beaucoup de nos amis et alliés dans d'autres marines et d'autres armées
ont des opinions très fondées au sujet du risque climatique.
En 2014, j'ai eu l'honneur de m'exprimer lors d'un séminaire d'une demi-journée,
lors de l'International « Seapower Symposium »
devant 70 chefs de la marine, à ce sujet.
On prétend que Winston Churchill a dit -
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai, mais il est censé l'avoir dit -
qu'on peut toujours compter sur les Américains pour faire ce qu'il faut
après avoir tenté tout le reste.
(Rires)
Alors, je pense
que l'on est toujours en train d'exploiter toutes les possibilités.
Et je pense que nous allons nous en sortir.
Mais j'ai besoin de vous.
Voici ma demande.
Je ne vous demande pas de sortir vos déchets tous les mercredis,
mais d'engager le dialogue avec chaque chef d'entreprise,
chaque chef technologique, chaque chef politique
et leur demander :
« Madame, Monsieur, que faites-vous pour stabiliser le climat ? »
Voilà, c'est tout simple.
Car lorsqu'assez les gens s'inquiéteront assez,
les politiciens qui, pour la plupart, ignorent ces problèmes,
en tiendront compte
et il y aura un changement.
Parce que, je peux vous dire, la glace s'en fiche.
La glace se fiche de qui habite la Maison Blanche.
La glace se fiche du parti qui contrôle votre congrès.
La glace se fiche du parti qui contrôle votre gouvernement.
La glace fond, tout simplement.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)